what the florida government has done for
the water quality and they
i i can't trust them with how
irresponsible they've been with just the
quality of our oceans and of our
waterways like they're so incompetent
and they're so unwilling to fix such
serious problems just because
some billion dollar industry makes a
billion dollars here like what was it
the sugar industry in florida that was
contributing to all the
phosphate mining is the worst phosphate
mining is the worst thing that is
playing and they funded a lot of rick
scott's
campaign right of course they did yeah
and like some of the biggest marine labs
for water quality and research in
florida are funded by mosaic which is
the
multi-billion dollar phosphate company
it's just like
as long as that keeps happening i'm not
trusting a word that our government says
at all like if they they need to give
the people a reason to trust them you
know i shouldn't have to be persuaded
into trusting you i should see what
you're doing and want to trust you based
on the actions that are taken by
by you by the government you know they
need to do things
that people see impacting their
communities in a positive way and like
all i've seen is dead dolphins and
manatees and sea turtles so like they
cannot blame me for not wanting to trust
them when they have been extremely
irresponsible and like that's just like
that's just florida government you know
i can
you know the president knew about what
was happening here you know he
president trump signed that
um
i think it was like a billion dollar
bill for a reservoir to be built south
of lake okeechobee to contain the toxic
water
can you pull up google earth for me real
quick
you guys want to see something crazy
what color is florida
what color yeah from space
green yeah
it was it's not green anymore south
florida's not looking too green anymore
really yeah you want to see south
florida's most south of lake okeechobee
swamp and mangroves right it used to be
let's see
yeah
go down a little bit look at past lake
okeechobee
oh yeah the tip is browning a little bit
yeah you see that
and what is this from it's because the
historic water flow
of florida goes from north to south they
built a reservoir around the south end
of lake okeechobee to where water cannot
flow from lake okeechobee into the
everglades anymore they're sending it
east and west right right so the
everglades are drying out oh because of
the restricted water flow so like zoom
into the yeah like big cypress national
preserve zoom in a little bit more
like it's not looking good
no no it looks a little dry for sure
yeah for sure
have you ever gone down there
like look at all that that looks like
[ __ ] up there
yeah look at all the agriculture that's
why it's because they don't want they
don't want those that small city there
to flood people shouldn't live there for
one and water should be flowing from
lake okeechobee down all the way down
there all the way through right south
florida but it's not and it hasn't been
free and what is the reason that they
created those to prevent flooding
because people are stupid and when
houses flood we build big walls and we
send water elsewhere
it doesn't make any [ __ ] sense to
prevent flooding where though from a
small town south of lake okeechobee okay
okay
yeah and like you see all that
agriculture like all those farms
that's like mostly sugar
but uh yeah those shouldn't be there
either and your water used to flow you
know streams used to flow like when it
would rain too much you know water would
overflow south and i guess it was like a
really big hurricane and it just flooded
too much or something i don't know but
yeah we're restricting that we're
restricting this historic water flow in
florida it's another huge problem and
that's because our government's
incompetent and like
have you ever have you ever seen um have
you ever seen uh carlton ward's page on
instagram
he is like the most legendary florida
photographer wildlife photographer you
gotta pull it up look up carlton ward's
instagram page he uh he's like a super
big actor really big activist for like
preserving
um
like all the all the wildlife and like
the uh
undeveloped
land in florida and uh i think he just
got something passed or some big bill or
law that was just passed where we had to
keep a certain percentage of florida
undeveloped and like and uh natural i
forget what it was good but it was
there we go
this guy is a florida legend
he has he takes some of the [ __ ]
sickest all this photography is florida
he's got he's got like these super high
quality cameras all throughout
the everglades throughout all the
undeveloped landed floors got like
badass trail cams and they're motion
cameras right so they take like super
like go down to that one of that panther
down there right there
oh [ __ ]
log in
so like he gets these things of all
these crazy animals like in the middle
of the night just going through his
trail cams
and so yeah everybody who's lived here
long enough it's like
my biggest thing is if people don't know
they can't care so like educating people
on what's going on
with our water quality is very important
something i try to talk about frequently
through like my youtube videos but every
time i post videos about it it seems
like they're suppressed and they don't
get recommended and
i don't know whatever that's that's
another conspiracy for another day
that's another thing i noticed with uh
with youtube with this podcast is that
the um the amount of people that watch
it on youtube fluctuates so much but on
spotify it's always consistent
it's always like a consistent amount
like the same people that are subscribed
to it they always listen to it
but on youtube it's the complete
opposite
but yeah carlton ward's super
super big into this you super activist
for for florida wildlife
and you guys look you guys know about
like randall carlson yeah he's been he
was on this podcast like a month like a
month ago you guys had him in here yeah
he was sitting right where you are a
month ago really yeah no way that guy's
a legend you didn't see it no you just
pressed it i did not youtube suppressed
it it's because he's a
concrete randall carlson no way you got
this because he's a freemason they
suppressed it i love this guy dude
randall rules dude dude did you blow
your guys mind about all the cataclysmic
events oh yeah
gosh what i'm sitting in randall's chair
randall is a [ __ ] legend goat i would
love to just like go on a trip with him
to just like some crazy
ex
he's doing some stuff
and he's always seeing stuff he's doing
some tours in tennessee right now
uh where he's touring some what
and portugal oh yeah yeah so he's going
to um
why humans need to leave earth soon what
was his uh what was the consensus here
he thinks that we're [ __ ]
i mean
does the headline have to have what are
you talking about the the uh the clock
was you talking about like the clock of
where the cataclysmic events like spike
like there's way more likely to happen
in a short window of time yeah he's
basically saying that um
every
uh every i think it was
400 to i know every 600 000 years
there is an extinction level event from
either volcanoes or asteroids no he's
saying every like 13 000 years no that's
the younger driest
every i think it's i think it's
600 i want to say it's 600 000 years
there is either a super volcano like the
one that's underneath yellowstone yeah
or um
an insane asteroid a
group of asteroids that take take out
and and what do you think is happening
soon well
we are in like we are in like a a 100
year window right now of the exact
anniversary of the last time earth was
wiped out by a super volcano so
volcanoes are one thing and we're having
some crazy and the asphalt volcano
volcanic activity lately and the
asteroids is like i don't know i think
you they cycled every 13 12 to 13 000
years
i